foreign
a civil engineer turned data scientist
who decided to Simply learn okay why are
you possible
with a course from a premier University
[Music]
true champion who upskilled to win big
how big
a massive hike that transformed my life
Adonis change gears pretty early in the
race
but Russian wanted to explore more to
get ahead
simply learned from mechanical
engineering to a data analyst and a
podcaster in his free time Sr career
transformation simply learned industry
experts live
experts
difficult
with a well-structured course it felt
like a piece of cake that is simply
awesome what's also awesome is that
nitin didn't choose a quick fix
you just started data science into the
mix
nitin how did you change the game worked
on real industry problems to become the
real deal a joint family a regular job
responsibilities but nothing could stop
methane from getting ahead what an
all-rounder de Hoya Knight with flexible
learning you can always make it right
crashing your situation
you too will find your way to get ahead
when you simply done
simply learn get ahead with simply nuts
[Music]
a civil engineer turned data scientist
who decided to Simply learn
recording in progress with a course from
a premier University
[Music]
true champion who upskilled to win big
how big
a massive hike that transformed my life
done this change gears pretty early in
the race
but Russian wanted to explore more to
get ahead
simply learned from mechanical
engineering to a data analyst and a
podcaster in his free time Sr career
transformation
experts live
expert
s
difficult
with a well-structured course it felt
like a piece of cake that is simply
awesome what's also awesome is that no
salt
nitin didn't choose a quick fix
you just started data science into the
mix
nitin how did you change the game worked
on real industry problems to become the
real deal a joint family a regular job
responsibilities but nothing could stop
nithin from getting ahead what an
all-rounder de Hoya Knight with flexible
learning you can always make it right
bashing your situations
[Music]
foreign
hi folks uh we'll be starting in few
minutes uh meanwhile you can let us know
where are you joining us from I am
Russia Khan I'll be host for today's
webinar and we're starting the webinar
for free coding masterclass in few
minutes so meanwhile get settled in and
uh please let us know where are you
joining us from
hello everyone uh I am Russia Khan your
host for today's webinar and I can see
the introductions coming along chat I
can see folks have joined from Tamil
Nadu and uh Texas Oklahoma Pakistan I
can see from USC if I can see from
Andhra position you have to welcome
everyone we will be starting the session
uh meanwhile uh folks are joining in uh
we'll just uh go through the
ground rules quickly uh so uh all you
need to do is you need to put down your
questions in the Q a box if you have any
questions for our speaker today Carlos
who has already joined us and uh please
make sure to put down the questions in
the Q a box we'll be taking questions
from there and also I think someone
asked me on chart that is the session
been recorded yes you'll be getting a
follow-up email with the recording link
and also a bonus offer of the session as
well
soon uh let's talk about the agenda of
the session uh we'll be obviously
getting to know more about you and how
we can help you out better in terms of
uh career path of coding and uh we'll be
learning about how you can build an
online ticketing web app
and also we'll be taking you through the
program introduction of chaotic coding
boot camp and sharing learner outcomes
enrollment steps for the program and
also a special duration for the Q a part
now let's get to know each other a
little more better so uh would love to
know how many years of experience do you
have so you can see a quick poll on your
screen uh so let us know how many how
many years of experience do you have
before we start session
so you can see a quick poll on your
screen you can just quickly go and
submit your answer there uh if you're
currently studying you can select that
answer if you have zero to three years
of experience you can select that one if
you have three to five years of
experience third one and if you have
more than five years of experience
fourth one
okay I can see folks have already
started uh you know sharing their uh
basically experience uh I can see the
post moving so uh few of the folks who
have not voted please immediately go and
uh quickly vote on a poll you will be
seeing on your screen right now so how
much experience do you have before we
start the session
okay I can see uh most of the folks have
already shared how many years of
experience do you have I'll give 10
seconds more for a few of the folks who
have not shared yet
okay you can see on your screen how much
use of experience do you have a quick
poll
okay I'll be closing the session in uh
five seconds this poll
and five four three
two one
okay let us see like how many uh I think
I can see that most of the folks have
zero three years of experience and uh I
can see a few of the folks are currently
studying and a few of the folks I have
more than five years of experience so
that's great let's
start so this program is powered by
simply learn world's number one boot
camp and uh we are very proud that we
have trained over 5 million plus
Professionals in over 150 plus countries
and also we have 13 years of digital
skills uh training experience and we are
very proud that we are transforming
lives by empowering people via digital
skills so thank you so much once again
for joining now uh we have a speaker
Carlos zagara with us uh Carlos what do
you like to give us your introduction
yeah uh hi everyone my name is Carlos
Sagara and I am an instructor here at
simply learn I teach the Java Java
bootcamp right
um I have more than 20 years of work
experience as a software developer India
I didn't I IT industry mainly working
for banks insurance companies
communication companies and I also
possessed
around 10 years
uh
um of experience as an instructor I have
been teaching Java and other programming
languages
and
um my um my goal as as an instructor
more than
than teaching is to inspire you guys and
motivate you to move forward in your I.T
career right I am I am
um very happy to be here tonight and I'm
looking forward to see you in class
awesome thank you Carlos for a great
introduction I think uh before we start
the live project demo let's start with a
quick poll question uh so you can see a
quick quote on the screen right now so
we would love to know why are you
attending this webinar today so in order
to understand you know how we can help
you out better as well uh while we are
giving the live project demo and the
program review so you can see a quick
pull on your screen uh like why are you
attending this webinar today uh are you
looking for becoming a coding
professional uh if you want to learn a
new language or a skill or I'm here to
understand if software programming is
easy to learn and the fourth one is I'm
interested in working in new projects uh
for my portfolio you can see a very
quick quote on your screen uh before we
start the live project demo of online
ticketing web application
so let us know why exactly are you
attending this webinar today
okay I can see folks are pretty active
here they have already voted in uh for
most of most of the answers but would
love to know like why exactly are you
attending this webinar today for us to
understand how we can help you out
better with the program trivia the live
project as well
awesome this is a multiple choice
question so you can select multiple
options as well
okay I can see the biggest uh
reason here is I'm here to understand if
software programming is easy to learn or
not so that's great I think I'll give
like 10 seconds more for a few folks who
have not voted it uh so I'll just close
the poll in 10 seconds so you have 10
seconds more to answer the poll for you
the folks who have not voted so why
exactly are you attending this webinar
let us know
okay uh I'll be giving five seconds more
for a few folks who have not put in
and I can see uh the post still moving
in
okay so why exactly are you doing this
webinar
so you're looking to become a coding
professional you want to learn a new
language you want to understand if
software program is easy to learn or if
you are interested in working on
projects to add to your portfolio let us
know so I'll close this poll in five
seconds because I can see most of the
folks have already voted uh so five four
three two one
awesome awesome thank you folks like I
think we've got an almost 100
participation so I think uh Carlos we
can see that uh folks are written the
biggest reason being I'm here to
understand if software programming is
easy to learn and uh the second uh most
important one is I am looking to become
a coding professional and I can see a
few of the folks is voted for I am
interested in working uh on new projects
to add to my portfolio and also a few of
the folks I voted for I want to learn a
new language so thank you for so much
for sharing that with us so uh now we'll
start the session of online ticketing
web app over to you Carlos
okay Russia thank you very much
um so guys in in this course right in
this boot camp we are going to learn
Technologies to build web applications
right so basically we can if we if we
learn the Technologies of this course we
can build literally any web applications
right but today we're going to to want
to focus on an application that is very
popular right now which is to build
um an online ticketing weather right uh
can we go to the next slide please
Russia
right so there are different ways I mean
different Technologies different
um Frameworks that we can use but in
this bootcamp we are using the latest
Technologies and we are using
technologies that are very popular right
among software developers right so in
this case we are the proposed solution
is to build a web application using Java
in the backend and angular in the front
right so what happens is that a web
application is comprised of two parts
right so we have a backend application
that basically connects to the database
and performs all the server operations
and transactions and we have a front-end
part which is another application that
is in charge of displaying the
information to the user in a very
attractive way right so we have two you
know in a web application we have those
two components the backend and the front
and in the back end the thing knowledge
is that we normally use is Java right
and in the front in the front end we use
um we use JavaScript and in this course
uh the the framework which is basically
a library that we use is uh angular
angular is uh it's a framework it's a
JavaScript library we use angular for
build in the front end
and Java for building the packet so
those are the technologies that we are
going to or we use in this course to
build web applications right so for this
specific case right how we can build
um
uh uh ticketing an online ticketing
application right so here we we have
identified
um a case which is to sell the ticket
right so uh in this case right we are
going to follow a specific workflow
right so we have to in at the beginning
we have to display the list of movie
theaters right then we select the movie
theater we want to to go to then we
select the movie and the time then we
select the seat right we have we have
um we pay for the tickets with our
credit card or debit card and finally we
get a confirmation page so um Russia can
you please uh go to the next page
right so here we have we have the the
workflow that we that we are going to uh
follow to build this web application
right so we are going to list the movie
theaters select the T the theater from
the list all right select a time right
and the and the tickets that we want to
buy select the seeds display the summary
pay with debit card or credit card and
finally we get the purchase confirmation
right
um in this case you see we have we are
using our demo uh very popular
um website which is from from Cineplex
so so we're using uh this application so
you have an idea of more or less what we
are talking about uh Russia can you go
to the next
page please
so uh before we move ahead uh we just
have a very quick poll question uh just
to understand if folks are paying
attention to it or not so uh so let's
just uh launch the poll very quickly
before we move ahead so uh the poll
question is very easy uh what is the
proposed technology stack for building
the online movie ticketing booking
application so let's see how much
attention are you paying uh so uh you
can see the first option as well Java in
the backend and the react and the front
end uh you can see the second one python
in the back end and angular in the front
end and the third one Jabba in the back
end uh and angular in the front end and
the fourth one Ruby in the back end and
view JS in the front end and I think
before while I was reading folks have
already started voting in for the uh
answer I can see one answer one option
getting a lot of votes so that's great
uh let's give it like 10 seconds more
for few of the folks who have not voted
so what is the proposed technology stack
for building the online movie ticketing
booking application let's see how much
attention have you been paying so far
before we go ahead with the live demo
foreign
participation here folks thank you thank
you for being an active audience I'll
end the poll uh now because you've
gotten everyone everyone's voting let no
let's see I'll share the results so what
is the proposed technology stack for
building the online movie ticket booking
application uh we have gotten the
highest number of votes for Java in the
backend and angling in the front end
Carlos what do you think
yeah so that's the correct answer so in
this course we use a Java for the
backend an angular for the frontage
right in the fronted there are other
combinations that are that are also
valid like for example Java in the back
end and react is in the front end but in
this course we are we are going to focus
on on angular okay awesome thank you so
much folks for uh sharing your answers
Now quickly moving on to the next part
of the library
all right so here we have we have uh the
user interface of our proposed solution
right so first we show
the the
um the movie theaters right closer to
the location of the of the user right so
the the the the the application gets
gets the uh the location of the user
and based on that location we display
right a list of Cinemas close to his uh
to to the to the place where the user is
is accessing the website right so we you
can see to the right hand side we
display the distance so that way uh the
user knows how how far right or how
close the the the movie theater is right
and then they can select this uh by by
the movies that they want to see but you
see there uh we have uh some
um drop down menus where we can uh
narrow down our the list right we have
we can also see movies I mean in let's
say for tomorrow or or the following day
right
so here the user must select the the the
movie theater that they want to they
want to go
all right uh Russia plays the next
all right so once they selected the
movie theater
then then the next election is to to uh
the movie right so in this case the user
selected this Cineplex Cinemas
Mississauga right which is a movie
theater and then this user will be will
will see a list of of movies that are
that are being
um displayed in this movie theater right
so for example we have Oppenheimer upper
Heimer Barbie and you can see that each
of these movies they have times there so
the user can select the time that they
want to where they want to go to the
movie theater or also we we display some
details of the movie right there is a
button to show the the trailer the
category of movie the the the duration
of the movie
so let's say the user selects
Oppenheimer right and uh I think it's uh
the user selects three three times
PM Russia Blitz the next slide
right so once the user selects
the the movie right then the user has to
pick the tickets right so you see there
are three categories of tickets right
the general admin ticket right seniors
and child right so and each of those
tickets have different prices right so
let's say this user wants to buy two
general admin tickets right so you see
there right uh the the user added two
tickets
right there are additional options for
the point cards right so if the if that
the cinema is accepting normally Cinema
you know they have uh they have a point
card right and and uh we if the user has
a pointer they can input their number
there
right and once the movie is selected you
see a subtotal there
right and a proceed button so when the
user is happy with the selection the
user will click proceed and we will go
to the next page uh Russia please help
me help me uh yeah so then
uh the user will will see right
um we will be able to select your seat
right so you they can you you can see
here that once in green are the ones
that the user the user selected here we
don't have seats in red because if if
there are other users that already
bought those seats you will see them in
red but here in this um in this demo
nobody bought the ticket for that for
that selection for that day for that
time and the user selected the seats
right and um then what the user is happy
with the selection right uh the user can
click proceed
right proceed yeah the next one yeah no
that's a previous one the next one oh
yeah here yeah that is the next one and
then here we see a summary
a summary of uh of uh before before the
payment uh we see the the cinema we see
that they the time the number of tickets
the taxes the the the
user has to pay and the doctor right
once the user is happy with this
they can click proceed
and in the next page we can make the
payment
right so after after reviewing the
summary the user has to import their
credit card information there is also an
option if you want to pay with PayPal
right and
and then uh we don't see that button
here but there is another button proceed
so you will have to scroll down and if
the user finally information proceed and
this is charged to their to their credit
card and they get a confirmation page
right they free that confirmation page
and they can uh go to the cinema after
that
right I don't know if we have another
slide about this uh Russia no no we
don't yeah we don't so this is this is
the last page so so this is a type of
web applications that that we built in
this course right we are going to to
learn all the Technologies right all the
things that are required for building
this type of of web application and it's
not that hard maybe it looks like a bit
challenging a bit intimidating to build
this type of application but it's not
that hard right because in this course
we build we we we learn everything from
scratch so you don't need to know
anything right because in the course we
teach we teach all the Technologies all
the
um the uh the Frameworks and libraries
that we need for building a web
application like this
before we move ahead uh with the program
premium uh let's see like how much
attention you have been paying uh to the
library demo as well you can see a quick
pull on your screen before we move ahead
with the program review part uh so which
step in the ticket booking process
allows users to review their choices
before making a purchase
so you can see four quick options here
two seats pay with the debit or credit
card display a summary select the time
so you can quickly tell us by uh voting
for the correct answer which you feel
like which is the ticket booking process
allows users to review the choices
before making a purchase
I can see uh folks are pretty active
here
and I can see
okay okay okay uh multiple answers
coming in but
let's let's give it like 10 seconds more
for few of the folks who have not voted
yet
okay okay
I can see uh polls still moving in so
let us quickly know you can see a quick
pull on your screen before we uh talk
about the program preview and also there
will be a special duration for the Q any
part as well so folks who are putting
down questions in the Q a part uh please
make sure uh that you put down questions
in the Q a box not on the chat
uh because we might miss messages on the
chat here
okay I'll be closing the poll in five
seconds because I can see most of the
folks have already voted so that's great
okay so five four three two one let me
end the poll and share results so which
step in the ticket booking process
allows users to review their choices
before making a purchase so I think we
can we have gotten the highest number of
votes for display summary and few votes
for pay with a debit or credit card and
few for choose seats and select a Time
Carlos what is the correct answer
yeah so the correct answer is display a
summary display summary oh amazing
awesome so we have gotten folks who are
pretty attentive here so thank you so
much folks now uh like before we go to
the program preview part uh Carlos would
like to know uh basically uh what it
takes takes it away for someone to
become a coder today
what what takes yeah what it takes to
well uh if you want to become a coder
you have to persist a lot right and you
have to practice a lot and and also you
need to to
uh to have the the right guidance right
because there are a lot of Technologies
out there right so you can build these
applications maybe using Java using
python groovy c-sharp right and there
are different combinations right of
Technology but you have to choose which
which is the the right technology to
learn which is the right technology baby
in terms of of having more job
opportunities
so so
um
so basically uh going back to the to the
question right which is uh what is going
to
to help you become a a a good coder is
choosing the right technology to learn
right and practicing a lot and persist
right I know that uh coding sometimes
can be challenging but it's very
important to persist right it's like uh
I always tell my students right if you
buy if you want to become a basketball
star what do you have to do right if you
want to play like magic your uh like
like uh like Jordan
what do you have to do practice right
practice six hours seven hours a day
right so coding is is like that right so
you so if you have to if you want to
become a good coder you have to practice
and have the right the right guidance
uh thank you so much Carlos for
answering that uh I think uh before we
start the program review we would love
to understand what exactly is stopping
you from becoming basically uh taking up
the caltex coding bootcamp and also
becoming a holding Civics world so you
can see quick four options here let us
know your biggest concern uh so you can
see four options here I can't find a
fully comprehensive curriculum uh the
second one being I wouldn't get the
Practical exposure I need to become uh
job ready and the third one being I find
it difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos the fourth one my work skill
schedule wouldn't allow me enough time
for learning so uh let us know what
exactly is stopping you from becoming a
coding expert and also uh taking up the
caltex coding bootcamp the program
review which will be talking about very
soon so let us know your biggest concern
so we can understand where exactly the
issue is so we can help you out better
also I can see folks have already
started sharing their concerns on the
poll uh but just a quick nudge that you
can put on your questions in the Q a box
okay I've gotten a few questions in the
Q a box that's great uh so folks are
putting on chat you might miss it we
cannot scroll back and go to your
question so I hope you understand that
you can need to put down a question of
the Q a box you can find the quinoa box
uh on your screen if you join from your
laptop or mobile you'll find a q a box
you can submit your questions
okay uh you can I can see most of the
folks have already uh basically shared
their biggest concern what exactly is
stopping them from taking the caltex
sporting boot camp and also become a
coding expert so what exactly is the
concern I'll give it uh 10 seconds more
for a few of the folks who have not
shared their concern uh and also in this
particular poll it is a multiple choice
question so you can select multiple uh
choices as well if you feel like okay
these are the basically multiple
concerns I have
before taking up a character calling
Boot Camp or even become a coding expert
in general so okay I can see the polls
still moving in so I'll close the polls
in five seconds
so five four three
two
one
okay let me in Google let me share the
results with you folks as well so uh we
can see here the biggest concern here is
I wouldn't get the Practical exposure I
need to become job ready and uh I can
see the second biggest concern being the
I can't find a fully comprehensive
current color and also I find it
difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos and a few of the folks have voted
for my work schedule wouldn't allow me
enough time for learning so thank you so
much for sharing your basic biggest
concerns now uh we'll be taking you
through the program preview of caltex
coding mode cam so now in this boot camp
you get a comprehensive and Industrial
learning path uh which is available 24 7
by simplylearn and also you get Hands-On
projects for practical experience just
like we have given a demo of online
ticketing book app you will get to work
on similar industry projects as well and
you will get access to online virtual
classrooms uh and also you will be
getting flexible to fit your schedule uh
basically program as well so the program
duration I think someone asked me uh
what is the program duration of this one
so six months is the program is and you
can just finish it by giving five to ten
hours per week
so uh thank you so much uh for your for
your concerns now uh and and end of all
you will be getting a caltex ctma
bootcamp certification which you can see
on the screen right now from Target uh
so sorry and also certificates for core
and elective courses which you'll be
sharing uh in the in upcoming slides and
also git portfolio to show your
accomplishments and you'll be receiving
up to 17 cus for uh from caltex cdme
that that is equivalent to 170 hours of
learning to it and also our caltex ctme
Circle membership uh in this circle
membership replicating uh in touch with
a lot of alumni from across uh diverse
Industries and iOS companies they'll be
coming from and also uh simply under
community that supports you so also uh
you'll you'll get recognized at an
online convocation as well so the
interesting part about the online
convocation is that you cannot just
invite your closest friends or family
you can actually invite your relatives
and you know everyone to this online
conversation and that makes it
now uh talking about the eligibility and
prerequisites so you don't have to uh
come from a non-programming background
and uh you can you need to have a high
school diploma or at least you need to
be 18 years of age uh to take up this
program and also you don't have to have
a work experience for this one so uh
Carlos just one quick question uh like
uh coming from a non-programming
background or not having a non-party
programming background when you are
taking up this course have you seen
students succeed when they don't have a
non-programming background
yeah yeah actually I have a lot of the
students that are coming from other
other backgrounds like from sales
marketing and they want to they want to
start a career as a software developer
right and they have to succeed it's also
true that they will have to put more
effort than a student that is coming
from from uh from IIT background but uh
it's it's a very very very probable
okay thank you so much for answering
that and also uh you don't uh basically
need a graduation certificate as well
you need to just have a high school
diploma or need to be at least 80 years
of age so that's great and having no
work experiences you know also okay okay
when you're taking up this project
uh so now how this program basically
prepares you uh should be talking about
how this program builds your development
skills step by step
Carlos can you take us through the steps
yeah sure so uh you see here from the
going from the bottom to up right so
today we are in induction right session
for Caltech coding bootcamp right so
then you're going to see uh four
additional squares at the top right
planning and UI design back end and
database development API endpoints and
communication and integration and
deployment so this course right
um is delivered in six months and it's
comprised of
for uh faces right so the first one is
planning and UI design so in this first
part of the course we we teach you guys
how to build the UI of the application
right how and also we learn about how to
plan your work right so that is the
first part of the course right the
front-end part right in the second part
of the course which is the back end and
database development we learned
Technologies for the backing so we
learned Java Java syntax we learned some
Java Frameworks and we also work with
with database so that is covered in the
second part of the course right phase
two then in in phase three we learn
endpoints right which is for creating
web services right so the front end and
the backend application they need they
need a way of communication right we
have to follow us standard right so we
have to create web services to to send
the information and to receive
information from the from the front end
to the back end and to the back end from
the front end so that part is covered in
the third phase of the course and
finally we have integration and
deployment so when we build our
application those applications you know
they are running locally on our
computers right but those applications
cannot be used until we deploy them on a
server right so in this course we are
going to learn how to deploy them in a
cloud environment right so
um so those once the applications are
are are deployed there anyone can access
them right so actually yeah we have to
put some security so only the users that
are authenticated should have access to
our application and so that's what we
learned in the last phase of the course
and finally to graduate you have to
finish the Capstone project
right the custom project is an
e-commerce site that's the the project
that we are suggesting for for this
bootcamp right which is I mean the this
online ticketing system is like an
e-commerce right that sells tickets
right but in this course we are we are
using
um for the for the Capstone and
e-commerce
thank you so much Carlos for taking us
to the steps uh also talking about the
electives uh the Celtic coding bootcamp
master class this is an optional uh
elective and you can take it take this
up you know it is a as up to you up to
your choice and also this elective comes
as a part of the program so you don't
have to pay anything extra for this one
uh now uh moving on to the Capstone
project which you can showcase to your
future employers so uh Carlos what
exactly is a caption project and how
does having a caption project in your CV
helps you when you are actually trying
to you know find jobs and also it this
gives you a real uh time experience as
well right uh which basically you don't
have an experience maybe like you know
in this software field uh while you're
taking up this boot camp as well
yeah so it's very important to have
something to show to our potential
employers right so in this boot camp we
are going to create
um
called repositories on GitHub so you
have your the code right but it's also
important to show the projects running
right so
um so the Capstone right the the
Capstone project will help us to have
something to show to our employers right
so there in the custom you will put in
practice all the things that you have
learned through the bootcamp right Java
angular
uh the cloud platform databases right in
this course we're going to use MySQL
right which is a relational database
there is also an option to use mongodb
which is a nosql database but
um mainly we are going to focus on a
relational database which is uh MySQL
so you can create your own page on the
web to Showcase your skills and also
build a complete profile from scratch to
this bootcamp and also Implement and
Reserve code to share reversity as well
so and also uh we'll be talking about
the global leaders as program advisors
so here Rick Hefner who is the caltex
cpma executive has over 40 years of
experience in system development and has
served an academic Industrial Research
positions uh and also we have Dave
parado as advising Professor uh who
actually is a software Visionary and
entrepreneurial agile project management
expert uh also uh Carlos here with us
who actually also is an expert who also
will be uh at training in this program
uh and uh other highly qualified
trainers as well who are experts in this
field uh Carlos can you tell us a little
bit more about this
uh sorry can you tell us a little bit
more about the global leaders and
trainers who will be a part of this
program along with you
yeah well
um I am in charge of instructing the
course right but we also have people
that that are going to be we support you
and your main your learning process so
we have uh
um there is an assistant there is going
to be assisting you with uh with any
questions that you may have right during
the course I'm going to be available as
well right we have uh
um another uh person that is helping you
with the technical part right of the
project the customs
so we we are a team that is going to be
supporting you in class
thank you so much Carlos for taking us
through that uh now moving on to the
learner outcome
share your success stories here like by
Andrea my Dosh uh Andrea has completed
this uh complex curriculum which
actually helped her giving a deep
understanding of the domain and also the
Blended learning model delivered by the
industry experts along with 24 7
learning support practice labs and
flexible schedules made it the best
coding bootcamp for her and we have
comma zagal here with us as well uh we
uh command basically completed this
coding bootcamp with simply learn and uh
he shares that it was a fantastic
journey and he has learned a lot and
gained knowledge in various topics like
back in front front-end devops and more
and also uh we you will be getting
siblical as a service uh through uh
basically uh job portal you will get
exclusive access to that and you're
getting a resume review and rewrite
Service as well you'll be getting
one-on-one interview Service as well uh
post uh completion of the certification
uh where you're looking for jobs you're
preparing for an interview so that is
always always helpful
now uh so let us know are you interested
in enrolling into the caltex quoting
boot camp so you can see a quick poll in
the screen this will help us stand if
you're interested in enrolling into the
program you can select the option you
get on the poll you see here and uh this
is for this particular attendings
webinar you'll be getting a bonus as
well so uh so if you are interested in
enrolling it with the program you can
see a quick pull on the screen you can
let us know if you are interested in
Rolling to the Caltech coding bootcamp
uh meanwhile I can see folks have
already started sharing their interests
in towards enrollment uh but uh just to
let you know we'll be taking the Q a
questions just in some time so please do
do go and put down your questions in the
Q a box also a messaging on chat we
might miss it so please do uh share your
concerns about the program or the
cooking career in general or the Q a box
meanwhile folks who are still uh sharing
uh if they are interested in enrolling
the character coding bootcamp I can see
a lot of interest to towards the
enrollment so that's great but I'll give
it like 10 seconds more for folks who
are still thinking about it so let us
know
okay I'll be closing the pool in 10
seconds I can see the polls still moving
in I can see a lot of interest coming
towards the enrollment uh in caltex
coding boot camp so thank you so much
for sharing that uh but please do let us
know for a few of the folks uh would you
like to enroll into the caltex coding
bootcamp you can see a quick quote on
your screen this will help us understand
in order to ear to you and the scenery
learning consultant will be reaching out
to you uh with the admissions offer and
also taking you through the program in
much more detail if any questions you
have about the program as well
uh for a few of the folks asking on the
chat here about the fee of the program
I'll be telling you that process so
don't punish it
p and the cohort part
okay I'll be closing the poll in five
seconds because I can see most of the
folks have shared their interest uh in
enrollment in the program uh so five
four three two one let me close the
board so I can see almost 90 percent of
the phone have said yes into enrollment
uh for that to help me out
so uh about the program we know I think
few folks were asking on the chat here
about the program fee of excluding
bootcamp so the program fee for this one
is eight thousand uh dollars and uh for
uh folks looking for financing options
we have that available as well you can
just uh go for as low as seven seven or
four dollars per month and also if you
have any questions you can always uh
mail us at ask us at simplynan.net uh
also just to let you know that we have
very limited seats we only take of 225
to 30 folks per cohort uh so uh just to
make sure that we're getting all the
attention that is required now moving on
to the enrollment steps uh so there are
very three simple endowment steps you
need to submit an application uh you can
apply it ask us at simplylearn.net I'll
be sharing that email on the chat here
and uh once you have submitted your
application you can basically your
application will be going for a review
and once your application is reviewed
we'll be reaching out to you with an
offer letter uh for admissions and also
uh few of the folks uh who have asked uh
I think the Q a box as well about the
cohort I'll be sharing that I'm just
sharing the email here on um on the chat
here
just to help you out with the email part
before we move in so you can see the
mail here on chat you can submit an
application there which will go for
review and also you'll be getting an
admission call uh from similes learning
consultant based on that uh about the
program schedule it will be starting on
October 15th the classes will start and
the induction Sensation will be starting
on 16th of October and uh and I have
shared the email ID here if you have any
more questions you can always reach out
to us at ask us at simplynan.net and
again I'm letting you know we have very
limited seats we only take 25 to 34
spark or hot just to make sure you're
getting all the attention that is
required you know while you're taking up
this character coding bootcamp now uh
for the folks who have shown interest
towards enrollment into the program uh
we would love to know how soon are you
planning to enroll so this will help us
understand when exactly we want to reach
out to you uh and when exactly you want
to end donate to the program you can see
a quick pull on your screen right now uh
if you're planning to enroll immediately
you can select the first one if you're
planning to enroll within three months
you can select the second one if you're
planning to enroll between six months
you can see the select the third one if
you're planning to enroll with from more
than six months from now you can select
the uh fourth option
so I can see folks have already started
sharing when exactly are they planning
to enroll uh I would suggest for the
folks who have shared interest in
enrollment program please do share us
when exactly are you planning to enroll
uh because for editing this webinar you
will be getting a bonus offer as well so
in case you're planning to enroll even
after six months or you know within
three months so that's okay please do
not lose out of the bonus offer
replicating for attending this webinar
so I'll highly recommend to go and
select that and I I think few of the
folks who were not sure about the
enrollment part as well uh I would say
key if if you're planning to improve
more than from more than six months
that's enough time uh for that but uh do
not miss out on the bonus offer which
you'll be getting for attendance webinar
so please do that and uh I can see uh
most of the folks have shared when the
exactly uh plan to enroll but I'll be
giving 10 seconds more uh for folks to
choose when exactly they want to enroll
meanwhile uh I can see questions coming
in on the Q a box
okay I'll be giving five seconds more
for a few of the folks who have not
shared uh when do they plan to enroll so
you can see very full very quick four
options on your screen here if you're
planning to enroll immediately within
three months within six months more than
six months from now you can let us know
this will help us understand when
exactly we need to reach our people
with the admission offer
okay uh I'll be ending the poll in five
seconds now before we move on to the Q a
part
uh folks who have already uh basically
submitted their answers uh when do they
plan to enroll uh please do put down
your questions lead to the character
coding boot camp
um and coding uh career in general so
please do make sure to put on your
questions on the Q a box and we'll be
taking those pretty quickly
okay uh I've closed the poll now now
let's move on to the Q a part uh so from
the Q a part I think uh you have to
reply to few responses here uh now uh
Carlos about the project part I think we
have a question will this be our desktop
and mobile friendly too like the online
ticketing booking application which we
have taken them through
yeah so the the projects that we built
in class are mobile friendly
right for that we use uh we use a
framework like bootstrap to make our
applications responsive right but in
real life companies prefer to use the a
mobile application right uh instead of
so for normally companies they have they
have two types of applications right the
public web application for for users
that prefer to use their computer right
and for users that prefer to use their
phone uh normally we we create a web
application right using maybe uh Swift
or for for
uh iPhone
or cuddling for for users for Android
users or maybe react native which is
multi multi-platform right that's what
normally companies prefer but the
application that we built is mobile
friendly right using uh a framework like
booster
I hope it answers your question thank
you thank you so much Carlos for taking
you know I think we have one question uh
what advice would you give to someone
considering a career change into the
tech industry to this boot camp
um well um I know it's intimidating
right but you if you really want to
become a software developer right I
suggest to uh take the chance
right to do jumping right and put and
put a
right I'm not saying that it's going to
be easy right they never say that right
it takes effort right so you have to
persist to take effort and I have seen I
I had a lot of the students I I I had
hundreds of students I mean in this
almost uh 10 years of teaching and I
have things too that with no with no
programming background they at the end
they they get a job in in the industry
maybe working for a bank or a
Communications company but it takes up
right it takes practice
uh thank you so much Carlos I hope that
answers your question please let us know
in chat here uh also I think we have one
question how can someone effectively
showcase their coding bootcamp
experience uh on their resume in England
profile you know once they've completed
the certification as well
what all things they can add
so so uh there there are different ways
that you can you can
um
you can uh like uh
show your abilities to your potential
employer right one would be to create
your own website right so so instead of
having your resume well I mean besides
having your resume you can create a
website where you put your resume in an
area a very nice way right so you put
the link in your in your in your resume
you can share that with with everyone so
they have access immediately to your
resume also you can improve your
LinkedIn profile by adding some pictures
some interactive things so
um
so um
you uh you get attention for from from
employers also you would need to create
a nice GitHub uh profile with some
projects where we with with nice code
right and deploy some applications on on
a cloud platform so everybody can access
them and access them another thing that
is I think is I mean it's very important
is if you can contribute to open source
projects right so that will that will
put you in contact with with a lot of uh
people that are that are working uh in
the IT industry right and it's very very
frequent that you you see people getting
jobs just because they know somebody
right the and uh in the IT industry
right so it's very important also to
build your your network right maybe like
this participating in contributing in
open source projects right or even I
mean there are Java groups right uh
everywhere right in North America so you
can go to meetups and you search for a
Java group for example and you start
um you assist to the events and normally
they have at least one event per month
right with a speaker and they they uh
talk about a specific Java topic and
then you can meet people there right so
you build your your network right and
you also
um can and can meet new people discuss
your your
um the things that you want to learn
with them they also will share with you
the things that they are doing right so
you get involved in the in this
environment right uh programming
environment right so that also increases
your chances of getting of getting of
lending a job in it
uh thank you so much Carlos for
answering that let us know in chat if
that answers your question or if you
have many questions I think we'll be
that was the last question you'll be
reading for the Q a box uh now moving
towards for folks who have shared their
interest towards enrollment and also let
us know basically how soon are you
planning to enroll you can see a quick
follow your screen here uh basically if
you need assistance in enrolling into
the caltex coding bootcamp you can see a
quick quality screen yes or no uh I
would highly recommend to take the
assistance because why not take the
extra help you're getting right uh when
the simply learns learning consistential
will be reaching out to you with an
admissions offer uh for caltic coding
bootcamp so uh for the folks who have
shared their interest towards enrollment
and also shared us with us you know how
soon are you planning to enroll uh
please let us know if you need an
assistant program you can see a quick
pull in the screen
okay I can see uh folks have already
started responding and sharing uh their
interest towards the assistance uh
please let us know on poll here if that
will help us understand if you need the
assistance to enroll into the program
so I'll be keeping up this Poll for 10
seconds uh for folks uh who want to take
the time uh while voting and uh we'll be
closing the poll in 10 seconds
okay I'll be giving five seconds more uh
for the poll uh I can see most of the
folks have already shared their interest
uh if they want if they need assistance
into enrollment or for the caltic
cooling boot camp so I'll be giving five
seconds more so five four three two one
let me close the code
so thank you so much for sharing with us
if you need your assistance now we
actually are done with the webinar uh
thank you so much for joining us folks
uh thank you Carlos for taking us to the
live project demo of Orlando keeping a
web application and also through the
program preview of card decoding
bootcamp thank you so much Carlos
thank you Russian thank you uh thank you
folks for joining as well we'll be
coming up with more webinars uh every
day and thank you so much folks will be
ending the webinar